when i look back like pretty much all of
high school my hair was literally
bubbling no the thinking was just like
the longer the better the more the
merrier but no no i used to get a
haircut and like trim half an inch and
have mental breakdowns like literally
crying pulling my hair out in the
bathroom i can't believe i was so
mentally ill back then and i'm so glad
i've made it and i feel like when you're
younger you have all this hair and you
just like use it to hide because you're
like young and insecure and you just
think like i'll put some hair on it also
as like a chubby young person you really
use hair as like a security blanket and
you think like okay it's hiding all my
imperfections and you look back years
later and realize
no it's actually highlighted it's just
adding like
to everything and you you put it
so far in front of your face you look
like you have a beard
and then from the back you have no hair
and it looks like a
like literally put some hair behind your
head it won't hurt you